[Music]
at the end of the day this small
business cleans up more ways than one
Ian seed is the owner of Denver release
a state licensed marijuana dispensary çb
shots the blinds and locks the doors
before he counts the day's take on this
night he's got lots of money to count
because he's been dealing only in cash
the bank that ran his credit card
transactions figured out what he was
selling first we lost American Express
and then one day we just didn't have the
ability to process credit cards we got
an email saying you're being cut off
that's because in the eyes of the
federal government seems business is
selling an illegal substance marijuana
how do you deal with animal cash
business it's very very difficult when
you're storing cash moving cash having
to pay people in cash all of that in
cash there are a lot of people that are
operating on a 100% cash basis I'm aware
of people who have been through over 20
banks in in four years to make matters
worse shortly after his credit card
processing stopped working his other
banks shut down the rest of his accounts
altogether they sent us a letter saying
due to recent federal pronouncements
we're shutting your account down
but we pushed back we got the United
States Congress people involved fed up
with operating like a criminal
Steve took his fight to Washington DC
federal government has scared
many of the bank's into not allowing
legal medical marijuana dispensaries
that bank accounts with it Colorado
congressman jared Polis has proposed
legislation that will remove marijuana
from the controlled substance list Wow
so banks working with marijuana
businesses won't be breaking the law
it's absolutely critical if these
business can have bank accounts it'll
help us in law enforcement traceability
making sure that criminal cartels are
not involved with the business and make
sure that people are paying their taxes
and following a lot and those taxes
could add up the legal marijuana
industry is estimated to be worth at
least 1 billion dollars but as long as
marijuana is illegal in the eyes of the
federal government E&C will have to
disguise his income we have put some
measures in place here so that our cash
doesn't smell like enemy put it in a
separate room we put it in a separate
safe it goes into a bag there's a safe
inside of a safe there's no reason to
rub it in somebody's nose and say here
smell this cannabis infused cash the
bank's gonna say yeah no that's not
gonna fly that is probably the the
quickest way to lose your name
[Music]